hey guys it's Justine and today I have
something very special this past wwgc I
think was probably the biggest one that
they've ever had they packed so much
into it and inside of this box we have
the brand new 15-inch MacBook Air and I
could not be more excited and I
definitely did not expect to be unboxing
something this soon after the event so
let's get into it
that's right our darling
air now has a big brother or sister the
15-inch MacBook Air comes stock with the
M2 Chip an upgraded speaker system 18
hour battery life while retaining the
silent fanless system of its smaller
counterpart
I got the Starlight one it's always a
mystery of what color are you gonna get
for your review version now in the 13
inch for the previous one I got the new
midnight color and this is the Starlight
I did get to see all four colors at WWDC
and not gonna lie The Starlight is
absolutely beautiful I kind of wish that
the macro Pros came in this color
because I 100 would have definitely got
the Starlight MacBook Pro
oh I'm so excited this is really the
only 15 inch MacBook in the entire Apple
ecosystem right now because they've got
a 13 a 14 and a 16 there's no middle
ground this is it wow it's definitely
heavier than 13. and the 13 is so small
The Starlight is so pretty
oh my goodness I'm gonna go from having
the 14 inch MacBook Pro to now being a
15 inch MacBook Air user why am I like I
am I don't know should I open it I
should open it it's probably gonna turn
on automatically
beautiful the sound that is music to my
ears oh you're so beautiful it's so
weird looking at it because I'm so used
to the MacBook Pros where they have
speakers either on the side or here on
the top but it's just a very seamless
design having gone from the 16 inch then
to the 14 and now to the 15 this is the
size I'm
had the 15
s and we were like oh we need to have
bigger and then we got the 16 and then
we're like oh I want it's too big
what wow it looks so good let's see what
else is in the Box
I mean I know what else is in the Box
there's going to be a magsafe adapter
and there's two options now you can get
the dual USBC charger or a 70 watt
charger
I was fully expecting to see the larger
one so that was a genuine shock that
this is what we have look
baby this might be one of my favorite
accessories of all time this dual
charger I have several of these this is
incredible and I like that they give you
the option to either choose between this
or a larger fast charge option which if
this was me getting this for myself I
would probably get the fast charge but
this is super small portable compact
love it and then it also comes with a
color matched Starlight magsafe cable
look at her she's beautiful it's not
white it is a very light
Starlight I mean this is pretty great
that this is the charger like look how
small this is you're not going to be
getting the super fast charge but this
is still pretty awesome bigger computer
smaller charger let's look at the
stickers we have to there's Starlight oh
and they've got like a new paper backing
now those are nice so here they are both
next to each other now just like the 13
inch this new 15 inch comes in four
colors a silver space gray midnight and
the Starlight now the one that I have
here again is the beautiful Starlight
color and this has 16 gigs of memory
with a one terabyte hard drive and when
I was editing off of this 13 inch for
this review this one only had 512 and if
there's anything that I can definitely
recommend if you're gonna upgrade is you
might want to get a little bit more
storage yes you can always use an
external drive but if you are a video
editor and you can go to the one
terabyte highly recommend now obviously
the biggest upgrade with this new
Macbook Air is the larger display it's
15.3 inches from corner to corner and
even though the black borders and Notch
are technically the same thickness as
the 13 inch they seem so much smaller
now because of that larger screen size
and while it is a half pound heavier
than the 13 inch version it's pretty
much the exact same height coming in at
0.45 inches the first thing that I
noticed when I picked this up is it was
heavier than the 13 inch but this View
feels very similar to my 14-inch MacBook
Pro so this is kind of falling somewhere
in the middle there but it definitely
doesn't feel as light as the 13 inch so
if you are looking for something super
light and even more portable than maybe
the 13 inch might be for you but this
extra screen real estate and the
enhanced speakers like there are so many
upgrades to this and the fact that there
isn't a 15 inch MacBook in the lineup
the 16 inch might be too big but this is
just a perfect fit right in the middle
between all of them now this 15-inch
MacBook actually shares a lot of the
same specs as the 13 inch it has the M2
Chip with an 8 core CPU a 10 core GPU
and up to 24 gigs of unified memory and
you can spec it out with two terabytes
of storage now they both support the
same media codecs including prores and
prores raw they do have the same 1080p
FaceTime HD camera and a three
microphone array the other thing that's
is they have the same exact battery life
you can get up to 18 hours on both of
them now you might be thinking now wait
a minute isn't this a bigger device
shouldn't it have a bigger battery but
the thing is this 15 inch does actually
have a larger capacity battery but
because of the larger display it's using
more energy so that extra battery life
kinda gets canceled out another factor
that could be contributing to the extra
energy usage is the upgraded speakers
the 15-inch MacBook Air now has a
six-speaker sound system with Force
canceling woofers and obviously it
supports Dolby Atmos with spatial audio
so I'm definitely excited to test that
out and compare it to the 13 inch
[Music]
foreign
just sat down at the park to do a little
editing and this was my first test now
obviously I've used the 13-inch MacBook
Air Now using the 15 I kind of forgot
how fast it is because I've just been
using my MacBook Pro for so long now and
I'm beyond impressed I just dropped in
all of those 4K clips that we just shot
of the unboxing and it was so incredibly
smooth I'm editing in a multi-cam
timeline right now and I'm quickly
switching back and forth between these
clips and I'm even running in better
quality and there hasn't been a stutter
yet is am I switching to a MacBook Air
now
I don't know maybe so I've been editing
on the MacBook Air 15 inch and my
conclusion is this unfortunately doesn't
feel like a MacBook Air because it is so
powerful and just the display is so
vibrant the pro and air category has now
I feel like kind of merging together the
only thing that sets this apart from the
pros I feel like is the fact that it
doesn't have the speakers on the front
and it's so thin obviously you are going
to be getting more power with the pros
but for pretty much my everyday simple
editing and when I say simple I'm
editing with 4K and AK footage and it
still is handling it like a pro it's
making me so confused on what to even
recommend to people anymore because this
is so impressive I just can't even so
the first thing I want to show you is my
timeline that I've been working on with
this video this is all 4K this is
actually a multi-cam timeline so I can
Cruise in here we've got both of our
frames there this makes it super fun and
easy when I'm editing I can just go
through and select if I want my first
angle or my second angle look at that
everything super smooth it's running so
great now another thing that I have is
I've got a bunch of 8K prores footage so
I just kind of want to throw this in
with to an AK timeline and see how it
performs so all of these clips are 8K
prores let's just toss it into this
timeline see how it runs
I mean
zero stuttering it's just it's just it's
running perfectly smooth
wow all right well I'm shook like does
this mean that I could get away with
working on just a MacBook Air
I definitely would have to completely
spec out
the solid state drive because I don't
think I could survive with one terabyte
like I already filled it up and I've
barely got all of the footage for this
entire project on here two AK Clips
stacked on top of each other let's throw
another one
how that looks
I mean it's running
it's running great smooth no stuttering
nothing
hmm okay looking good to me so now I
want to test out something else how
about a little bit of Lightroom okay so
here's some photos from a shoot that I
did for my pink iJustine cables which by
the way if you haven't got one already
um you need to you're missing out so I'm
gonna find one of those photos I mean
I'm scrolling through here and these are
just loading in so fast like basically
just like nothing I mean this is not
even flinching at editing any of this
it's just working super smooth this
makes me so excited for the future I
mean I know I'm living in the now but
the fact that this is so powerful and so
small and thin like what's next what is
next I don't know
okay now I'm gonna copy that to the next
one I mean that's just definitely not
like a super great edit I'm not proud of
that so don't think wow she seems that
is that your
editing skills no it's not great but I
do want to show you how quickly you can
just copy and paste that on other images
and it's working almost instantly okay
well we did that now what about gaming
got a couple of games here I'm not gonna
play NBA 2K 23 because I'm not good at
it
at all how about hot lava and the cool
thing is I can sync up a controller to
this you can connect an Xbox controller
a PlayStation controller or even a
Nintendo switch so we're going to
connect an Xbox controller and it
automatically pops up here super quick
there it is time to game here we go
let's go this game is actually really
fun oh my gosh okay here we're in we're
in we're in
oh
mine's burning
good
this makes me so nervous oh man okay
here we go we got this no well we almost
didn't
okay so this is running pretty great I
think we get the point of course it's
gonna run awesome another thing is how
quick and responsive things open up
let's just pop open a little pixelmator
Pro I'm new to this app but I just
started using it when I saw that Apple
does a bunch of demos with this so I'm
gonna browse for a file and I'm going to
show you guys how quickly you can remove
things from photos so you can do one of
two things you can select it with the
selection tool and then you can go over
here to the repair and you can click
repair selection and
it instantly just removed that raw this
is also pretty cool because you can just
use the brush tool and you can just
brush over something
and it's gone
um how about this Rock freaking gone
Gone Gone
like this is so impressive I need to
start using this more watching content
is also pretty awesome with these new
six speakers so you really do get that
Dolby Atmos feel like it's just going to
surround sound
speakers are really interesting
speakers too it's just like it's magic
it's like where were you even coming
from they sound really good so this does
have a 1080p webcam and obviously these
devices are going to be used a lot for
conference calls so let's um let's test
it out shall we it's so crazy to see how
far we've come because I used to use the
eyesight camera on my first MacBook
that's what I was shooting my YouTube
videos on so the fact that this is what
we have now like I can just hit import
and I can actually use this FaceTime
camera right here in Final Cut and it's
so fast look at this so good okay I'm
gonna just I'm gonna I'm gonna import I
just hit import
okay let's test this out hi I don't want
to move
um this because this camera back here
right here is focusing on you so let's
see how this looks and let's see how it
sounds let's bring that in and see how
it sounds hi I don't want to move
um this because this this camera back
here it looks so good
so let's see how this looks and let's
see how it sounds that is not a
flattering angle wow okay so I'm
definitely super impressed and like I
said at the beginning this doesn't feel
like an air it feels so much closer to a
pro that it also makes me wonder like
what are you gonna do in the pros to
make them even better all I know is I
feel like any Mac that you get at this
point with any of these silicon chips
you're gonna be so happy well thank you
guys so much for watching I hope you
guys enjoyed this video I would love to
hear from you in the comments below if
you guys have any questions about any of
the new Apple devices wwgc announcements
I would love to hear them and hopefully
I can answer them for you I'm gonna go
finish editing the video that you just
watched bye